[Music]
what's up y'all welcome to another
episode of flat line with your boy david
lucas here at dick dickboy studios live
man hey so uh i told y'all to leave
those comments under my youtube video
and i'm gonna read some of my favorites
y'all y'all was hitting a little bit
y'all was cooking man so let's see
david got his booster shot at
chick-fil-a see that that's pretty
decent man you know cause i might
david looks like he can't pick between
being a gangster and a fisherman homie
went into the barber shop asking for
worms and came out with that haircut
brother fine might ask
uh when david sweats he probably smells
like pot roasting collard greens you
racist [ __ ]
those are two of my favorite foods
david looks like the guy you call when
your vending machine snack gets stuck
i i mean i will push it
that was my profession in high school
you know little cute girls being like my
chips are stuck and i go and knock the
machine
let them get their chips
i think this is my favorite one uh yeah
uh david looks like blob marley
that's pretty good whoever said that man
that was
that was a good one man that was a good
one
all right man but we're gonna get right
into it i know y'all saw that uh
demolition man i mean uh tiffany haddish
got arrested for a dui she fell asleep
at the wheel
did y'all see her did y'all see that
hairdo she has tiffany hatter's got a
bleach tennis ball on her head bruh like
she looked like she preparing for the
lifetime biopic of dennis rodman like i
don't know what the [ __ ] she's doing bro
she look like the black version of
macaulay culkin
tiff what are you thinking and you're my
girl but that hair dude get the
going through a midlife crisis [ __ ]
i'm glad spotify
is uh siding with my boy joe rogan and
they're removing neil young's music
uh
i'll never hear it either way if they
remove it or add it or put it on my
playlist i'll skip over that [ __ ] i
don't know one nil
young song and shouldn't you be
somewhere and somebody be hiding your
medicine and your applesauce you old
fool what are you doing
this is a new generation dawg we're not
in the vinyl days bro like nobody gives
a [ __ ] about removing your music
joe rogan over you bro
when the last time you had a hit
all right that's what i thought
all right man we're gonna get into it
man you know the meat of potatoes bro we
gonna let the first person in the room
let's see if y'all can really hit me
though i'm waiting for somebody to like
give me a knockout punch
if it ain't snoop diggity dog
look at that boy it's good dick that boy
ate a pack of cigarettes for breakfast
get your chimney through haven't had
somebody here boy come on nick hey
everybody oh dirty bastard looking at
you the new dirty bastard
what you got for me dawg give me
something bro hey anybody ever tell you
you feel like the penguin off toy story
too
anybody ever tell you the top of your
head like a boy
look like your head off you feel like a
boy
look at your fat face and what
you got
dresser you're dirty i'm like i'm mike
i'm mike
i know you're like
are you is this the roast show yeah bro
you look like a cancer
patient no [ __ ]
nowhere on your body bro
you look like god damn
bro you look like a day walker from
blade [ __ ]
[Laughter]
sunlight ain't gonna do [ __ ] to you you
gotta put a stake through your heart
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] went to the car wash
to get his hair cut he said let me get a
wash a wax and a buff
it does look like that looks good right
how long have you been bald
yeah
bad long time yeah bro you look like an
enemy of a werewolf yo
[Laughter]
bro yo ass look like everybody hates
chris grew up
at the big-ass glasses boy
yo ass guy yo ass got f-150 windshields
for glasses [ __ ]
[ __ ] big as [ __ ] boy
you gonna need a pressure washer
baby what's going on you got to register
them glasses with the state boy they
need a license plate
oh yeah no ass got a non-operational
vehicle on your face
well you look like a daddy from a tyler
perry movie
yeah bro you look like you're the one
who cheated on what's that girl named
jill scott why does it why did everybody
get married why did i get married
[Laughter]
if you leave them blasters just sitting
around you're gonna catch some [ __ ] on
fire
thanks
when you put your glasses away you say
locked and loaded
look at you bro coming live from a
wheelchair ain't it
nah bro i'm just sitting on my desk the
professor x in venezuela
ah colombia bro come on yeah boy
your special power was heating food up
with your eyes
oh you look like the physical embodiment
of a sneeze bro
your neck look like it's too weak for
your head bruh
[Laughter]
gave up
[Laughter]
yeah boy your hair look like it's stuck
in a hurricane
tell your sound on bruh
cody back up in this [ __ ] looking like
a poisonous snake
[Laughter]
you look like you look like you gotta
you look like you got into a fight with
your grandma over her insurance card
[Laughter]
i like to see the graveyard you lost
your virginity again
you like the type of guy to drive a
hearse
[Laughter]
you look like a creepy guy who puts
child locks on his back doors and don't
got no children
[Laughter]
i got you now david there we go
there we go what's up bro what's up man
i had an amazing weekend i saw uh craig
fitzsimmons at helium comedy club in
portland you ever been there
uh no we about to roast
okay talk about your weekend you look
like ted nugent
all right i'm from the pacific northwest
so i'm gonna roast myself and see who
grows me better you look like you got
two deer carcasses in your garage
yeah i look like i just got done with
the
celebrating a year of not getting caught
for my part in the insurrection
yeah i seen you starting the capital
last january
you had on camouflage and using black
face
i got weird genetics i look like the
product of when the very first viking
[ __ ] the very last neanderthal nah but
i seen your truck the other day you had
a trump 2024 sticker
they rigged the election goddamn russian
yo how's that furniture is that thick
boy furniture yup you see us holding me
up yeah i don't know man the only thing
left stable in that furniture is your
child support checks
not bad i'm actually caught up on child
support [ __ ]
that's the best joke so
far that's the best one so far [ __ ] yeah
thanks man
what up there we go bro you look like
you're on the girls volleyball team at
your college
thanks why are we matching right now
pretty bastard
[ __ ] what's good i don't know bro you
tell me looking like the master zorro
steps up with that [ __ ] hair back
like that
you got to be the most handsome person
that work at your local cbs bro i swear
to god yo ass
i'm the manager
what do you do for a living
um did i try i'm about to go out
travel the us and [ __ ] rep my company
a bum
a [ __ ] a big bomb what's your company
uh motive
[Music]
huh
motive
it's a jewelry company online oh that's
my boy you just sent me that necklace
yeah yeah appreciate your brother that
[ __ ] took my neck the dark green
baby
i put that [ __ ] over the shower
hey
[Laughter]
hey man all of y'all were great man
y'all brought the heat this week thank
y'all for coming at me hard man you know
i got hit i got stunned a little bit but
i'm still waiting for that knockout
punch remember to still leave your best
roast in the comments i'll be reading
them every week and this has been
another episode of flat line make sure
you tune in next week and if you want to
be roasted send the dm to thick boy
studios instagram page all right man
y'all
you